Senator Wilford has to be one of my
biggest heroes.
I'm Sargent Shriver,
and Senator Welford were the driving
force behind,
um,
and institution and more than that,
a grand idea,
the Peace Corps that inspired me in so
many of my generation to understand that
we could make meaningful contributions
through public service and that those
contributions could have an impact on
the larger world.
I grew up as an Arab American already
feeling connected to a larger world,
the Peace Corps and so much of what has
grown out of it,
um,
gave me the ability,
it really motivated me and inspired me
in everything that I have sought to
achieve in my life since.
And uh,
as I have said on a number of occasions,
the ideals and the values and the,
the,
the mission of the Peace Corps and of
the spirit behind it really is what
first drew King Hussein and myself
together as we found common ground,
having grown up in completely different
worlds.
We found common ground through this
concept of public service and joined our
lives together to carry on.
I feel that I am a Peace Corps volunteer
to this day and will continue to be and
consider every peace corps volunteer a
sister and a brother.
And,
um.